is it scary onset you know what was the
creepiest moment on set for you guys but
is it scary is it is it are you are you
scared is it do you have scary moments
with disturbing this I'd say rather than
scared moments cuz you're comes a kind
of lack of terror with exhaustion
sometimes but there was real disturbing
moments and a lot of them provided by
being in the proximity fo skarsgård when
he was doing his thing what's more
important is it sort of studying the
performance of the original that Sophia
gave or is it sort of meeting Sophia and
and not learning more about her was the
performance she gave because it's such a
great blueprint for where who Beth was
when she was a kid and where she's going
of course I loved meeting her itself and
talking to her about how she approached
the character but most of our
conversations were about family I heard
the kids wrote letters did all the kids
write letters to you guys what what
stood out you know I mean I was
surprised what Jeremy wrote in you know
Ben's perspective as a child was kind of
similar to what I've been preparing
before I got to say a lot of it had to
do with Beverly and I guess his fears Oh
Ben's fears of you know becoming lonely
in life which kind of plays out so yeah
it's cool it's nice to know that I was
bang on and that kind of realm but I
took a look from watching the first film
to there's this beautiful moment where
Jeremy read Taylor plays young Ben he
when he first meets bed and he almost
blushes on cue which is incredibly hard
to do you know so I kind of took that
that feeling and infused it into the
adult version Isaiah I feel like Mike is
a very very important character in this
film because Mike is the only one that
stayed in derry can you sort of explain
his point of view and is he's the one
who brings everyone back together and
you can
he talked about his his place in this
film and how he serves the story he had
since he hasn't changed I don't I don't
think that he's ever gotten over the
things that happened in the first film
so I think he's just kind of trying to
do his best to come to grips with it for
27 years so when he discovers that
things start or starting to look
familiar
he feels that he has a what he thinks is
the best solution and I think I think
when you like you said it it's hard to
talk about it because uh because I might
give some stuff away so so I I just
think that that um when you see the film
you'll see how how he's adjusting to
dealing with all the stuff that he
remembered for the past kept with him
for 27 years did you all have let go on
a weekend retreat or something in terms
of finding the chemistry as an ensemble
finding the chemistry of these these
childhood friends who went on these
experiences together what did what did
you do to sort of find that find that
chemistry to karaoke but we filmed the
Jade of the Orient scene first and that
we all throws together and I think so
that that can actually be like really
unnerving because we all are just trying
to figure each other out as people and
then those performers and then we did a
lot of karaoke was there was there a
song is there a moment that uh that
everybody rocked out in it was like
that's your song you didn't know all the
words to common people like Jarvis
Cocker of great deal he's Bob Jarvis
bill and James the relationship that
your two characters have in the first
film is it provides a lot of comic
relief there's a lot going on between
the two you guys is that return in those
film there's a really long scene at a
bank
there's no anything very dry and
Richie's cares there's a book and she
was like yeah you know it's good his
character gets really frustrated cuz
this credit is like it a 648 and it's
not bad everybody's gonna yeah likes
2530 minutes yeah they kept fifteen of
it and I'm saying what was but what was
most important for you sort of him
becoming the older adult version of no I
mean you know it's just Richie's you
know he's just like you know a guy who's
a funny like a lot of comedians I know
he kind of masked things with jokes and
you know busting on people like this guy
and everybody and but there's a lot of
repressed feelings like all of them you
know dealing with trauma I mean the
movie well it's kind of date is not just
the hey what's all great horror films is
not just about horror I mean it could be
a it's about childhood trauma and
growing up with trauma and a collective
trauma between these people and they can
all we all have the same experience but
they all kind of the same disease these
characters you know they come back
together and so that's there's like an
interesting relate ability to it beyond
just the worst oh yeah it's speaking a
childhood trauma Beverly in this film as
an adult the blood is back I was just
talking to Andy apparently the most
blood maybe ever in a horror movie in a
scene and you see that has this
distinction what was what was that like
baby
just being covered in that blood you
know it's funny when I went to do it I
thought like it was a one day thing and
I was like alright I'm gonna do it
that's you know something that you're
kind of a little like uncomfortable with
but you think like it's over in a day
and then it lasted like six weeks
because I had to keep pouring it all
over me so it was but it looks amazing
and also I think it's important because
I don't want too much but for Beverly's
journey I thought it was really a cool
thing hmm Andy not to be about Stanley
weird what do you want to know where
where it where is where is he as we sort
of he picks up after the bank loan so
they left and then they say could you
tag in and I tagging of us trying to get
in on his credit and that scene actually
lasts 20 minutes and it's just him
printing scanning papers I lied yes
financial so what about where is
Stanley's character I mean you you you
you probably you meet him like you you
probably has every one of these
characters we're meeting them with the
phone call and they're in the middle of
their life there it's been 27 years of
repressed trauma and people are in there
and their various stages of success
Stanley has found a life that he loves
and a wife that he loves and a
contentment and so it would seem a piece
and we find him there
[Music]
you